for many today represents one of the
worst days of the year it is the
official deadline today because the 15th
fellow weekend to file your taxes this
year you the American people you have
already forked over more money to the
federal government than ever before in
history now even if you reside in a deep
blue City in a deep blue State the vast
majority of your tax dollars being sent
to the Washington sewer and swamp the
average American household is now
forking over almost 37 thousand dollars
a year to the feds wow so what is the
swamp doing for all of that hard-earned
money you have well under Joe Biden it
is not a pretty picture some would call
it a dumpster fire and today we have
three major examples are grossly you
know under managed mismanaged government
is just on the prowl every single day
now it starts at the very top you have a
president that is mentally checked out I
don't care if you want to say he is in
cognitive decline or Worse that's up to
you you but certainly the world sees it
you see it every American sees it China
sees it Russia sees it Iran sees that
North Korea sees it and guess what
according to His official scheduled
yesterday he worked for less than an
hour after spending a long weekend at
the beach but while Joe is daughtering
along well the woke attorneys and
academics and bureaucrats that are in
the White House they're the ones running
this country literally into the ground
on every level the incompetence is
almost unbelievable way to hear the
questions we have for you today on
Capitol Hill that incompetence was
glaring it has never ever been this bad
take a look at this to start the policy
of the prior Administration to separate
children from their parents was one of
the most heinous policies
in in our recent memory most certainly
very proud of the work of the family
reunification task force which I am
honored to lead what we do is we enforce
the law let me just say this but you're
not it is stunning to me
stunning to hear you say that the prior
Administration reunited children with
their parents when this is their fault
so you're not going to take any
responsibility for the indentured
servitude and exploitation of children
that is happening on your watch a moment
ago you were crowing about the fact that
you treated children so well and yet we
find tens of thousands of children who
are forced to work as slaves because of
your policies and you turn around and
blame a prior Administration Mr
secretary this is par for the course for
you you do it every time you appear
before this committee you do it every
time you appear before Congress I for
one am sick and tired of it and
thousands of children are in physical
Danger
danger because of what you were doing
record illegal immigration one year
after another after another six million
plus to date and more drugs more
fentanyl more heroin more meth more
cocaine have poured across our Southern
border under Joe Biden than ever before
more illegal immigrants have crossed
into this country than ever before more
women and children have been trafficked
sexually and otherwise and abused than
ever before look at this report quote
the Biden Administration ignored warning
signs they dodged blame for migrants
forced into child labor now why would we
be shocked take a look at your screen
you might remember oh remember those
those cages for kids at the height of
the coveted Pandemic those are Joe
Biden's cages now we all know that
Biden's borders are Kamala Harris she
was never going to lift a finger so it
really was up to secretary mayorkas to
fix this dire situation but mayorkas has
utterly failed and he tries to blame the
Trump Administration when we had very
little illegal immigration why because
Trump enforce the laws of the country he
did not enable law breaking like
mayorkas is doing like Joe Biden is
doing he didn't reward the law breaking
you have a career lawyer and bureaucrat
and mayorcus he has no idea what he's
doing and frankly he should be
embarrassed to even show his face in
public he has no business in this
position he's not keeping our country
safe and secure how many people have we
already caught on the terror watch list
but even more importantly how many
people on that list have gotten through
and come into our country to create
Terror cells right here in America these
people have no shame and sadly it's not
just the Border it's not just mayorcus
here get this you're going to love this
here's Biden's Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms director making a complete
idiot and fool of himself on Capitol
Hill today unable to describe what a an
assault rifle even is because the
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms director he
says I'm no expert in Firearms then why
do you have this job
in 15 seconds would you define an
assault weapon for me so
if you go after 15 seconds I'll just
interrupt you so so I'll go shorter than
that because I I honestly I do think
that's a if Congress wishes to take that
up I think Congress would have to do the
work but we would be there to provide
technical assistance I unlike you I'm
not a Firearms expert to the same extent
as you may be but we have people at ATF
who can talk about uh velocity of
firearms what damage different kinds of
firearms cause so that whatever
determination you chose to make would be
an informed one
uh we want a ban assault weapons but we
don't know what they are you would think
the guy trying to regulate and ban
assault weapons Firearms would have even
basic knowledge about Firearms another
complete incompetent ignorant you know
idiot working for your government this
guy is you know probably the worst of
the worst expertise clearly not a
requirement in the Biden White House now
take a look we're not done yet at
Biden's education secretary this is all
happening in one day he was completely
incapable and unable to answer a simple
question I don't think this is a hard
question I never thought you know I
would hear this in Congress but take a
look what is a woman that's the place
defined for me what is a woman
uh our focus at the department is to
provide equal access to students
including students who are lgbtq access
free from discrimination
is that so what's the def what's the
definition of a woman you haven't given
me that you haven't answered my question
I think that's almost secondary to the
important role that I have as Secretary
of Education my question is not
secondary my question is very simple
what is the deaf what does HHS say the
definition of a woman is
I lead the Department of Education and
my job is to make sure that all students
have access to public education which
includes co-curricular activities
let's pause for a second shall we did
you ever think this would be a real news
story in the United States of America do
you ever think that ideology always
taken precedent in the bite
Administration woke wins the day every
day now here's another example you
thought I was done I'm not done yet
Secretary of State wink and Tony blinken
in Japan today a few miles away North
Korea has been launching icbms right
near Japan from month after month after
month China's been conducting hostile
military drills in the Pacific the South
uh China Sea the Taiwan Straits and
threatening to invade our U.S Ally
Taiwan and yet Tony Lincoln blinken was
more focused on Japan's green energy
take a look
this is a tremendously exciting day to
have one of the most major embassies
that we have anywhere in the world make
this green transition really sets sets
the example and sets the stage to uh to
do even more across the entire State
Department Enterprise and as the
investor said we're fulfilling uh an
executive order by the president but the
fact that it's happening here in Japan
with Mission Tokyo is very very
meaningful
that guy a couple of weeks ago admitted
they did abandon our fellow Americans in
Afghanistan 175 that he knows of and
that some of them are being held hostage
they are all completely out of their
realm they have no business being in
charge of anything in within our
government uh is anybody out there any
of you out watching tonight are you
missing the guy that sent out Mean
Tweets especially uh taking on China
that's trying to take over the USA as
the world's sole superpower anybody
paying attention to that I guess Joe is
probably visiting more castles this week
it's clear that most of the officials
have never held down a real job outside
of D.C in their entire lives Common
Sense be gone nobody has any common
sense in that swamp and America's
geopolitical foes they are more hostile
than ever they're taking full advantage
Americans being held hostage let's see
in Russia in Afghanistan Mexico
elsewhere all over the world Global
Supply chains are still a disaster the
drug crisis worse than ever because of
open borders inflation record levels
interest on our national debt is costing
you the American taxpayer 400 billion
dollars or around 10 percent of our
entire federal budget even small things
like processing times if you want a
passport or a federal document request
or an application or a permit or a Visa
that's taking longer than ever before
and somewhere tonight as Biden is fast
asleep can't stay up and watch our show
Kamala is cackling away and you know
laughing and giggling as she always does
and mayorka's raging and blaming Trump
are you know the dogs biting and the bee
stinging there's a little girl or boy
being trafficked at the exact same time
being abused at our Southern border by
Mexican cartels no one in the white
house seems to give a damn uh that then
that should tell you everything you need
to know about the people that are in
charge they're letting this happen all
of this is preventable hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else